my queen kind of keeps him on it he
doesn't want to blow open the position
on the Kings side with the Queen's on
the board but once the Queen's are off
the board hey he's more than willing to
go for it okay so any ideas what I
played I mean each war is an idea it
doesn't necessarily ever stop him from
playing g4 if I play h4 he could play g4
I would take on Poisson but then on his
next move he might play a move like King
G to g4 or King G to rook h1 what did I
say my plusses were in the position help
me so if this is a plus I want to keep
it I'm also a little bit worried you
know from from my point of view I want
to keep my protected passport and I was
a little bit worried about the idea of a
3 B 4 maybe he would open up the
position on the Queen side so what did I
play yeah I mean that really does cut
out M as Michael said if I'm ever going
to utilize the B file and maybe one day
if I can provoke white to play b3 maybe
I could play a4 and cause a weakness on
the B 3 square ok oops what was that
yeah yeah yeah yes on the king true he
did but at this moment in time you know
that's maybe a future concern at this
moment in time what he was really proud
of you know let's face it was he's got
this beautiful blockading night on d3
which sits firmly in front of my
protective passed pawn and it kind of
radiates strength that not only does it
attack with pawn on c5 but it protects
the structure here so that should a g3
h3 g4 and the night here there'll be an
f4 f5 business now somehow I think when
and we copy things over I mean this is
like I'm annoying as can be okay just a
second
I believe it didn't how's that possible
it didn't copy over nicely okay so he
played I think I can't understand how it
didn't copy over he did not play of
course before my opponent played g2 g3
and although I kind of gave the house
away a little bit with my previous
comments I still would like to hear the
explanation voice once more why did
white play g3 in rocket science
yeah there's no wrong answers here
exactly
h3 G so it's kind of as gradual
thing and in our minds eye if we can
imagine kingi to h3g for we can really
see black getting pushed literally
backward right and also don't forget
that this knight on e4 reaches into the
d6 square so that in truth this knife
will almost never be able to retreat to
e7 because Knight d6 would be lights out
that would be just a knockout blow
so after you see Bishop e7 Bishop e7 and
now I don't know this is the only
controversy bless you bless you
not at all not whether this is a
controversial move or not but up to this
point I had been in total admiration
what yon had been doing made total sense
to me and I have expected the move King
G 2 H 3 and G for coming we'll see how I
handle that in the very near future but
yon made a move that was a bit of a
surprise but I can't say it's a bad move
I can't say it's a great move it's just
an interesting move
King F 2 now somebody tell me why he
might have chose King F T
and try to get back okay okay okay
that's that's an interesting idea other
ideas of King up to right exactly
exactly
well well sometimes you try to figure
that out right your opponent plays a
move that kind of takes you halfway back
a little it was like something you
expected but there was some kind of a
new ones well how's this for thought
where what potentially where potentially
is white week we're in White's camp is
there any weakness
yes England eath it well indeed III but
III is protected but potentially that is
correct
that's and another where else is there
yeah but I'm not exactly tired but I
mean how about pawn weakness I should
have been more strict it's their upon
weakness and whites can't so this
possibility small small small small will
agree there's a possibility that the
b-pawn is weak and maybe white was ready
to bring his King to e2 anyway that was
the best I could decipher okay
I played da da King up to okay well
whether or not whites intention is to
bring us King to the Queen side I don't
know but I do know this if I were in
white shoes I would really want to play
h3 rook h1 g4 and in case these pawns
get traded that open H file will be
great so I knew that H 3 and G for our
on White's agenda so what did I do
any ideas it's not like I have a great
number of options right some castles but
where would i Castle cuz I should I
castle long or short I mean either way
I'm walking into h3g for right that's
that's a real weak that's a draw I don't
like losing my pawns man I mean yeah I'm
an old pawn grubber you know I mean
you're like give me your pawns baby yes
h4 okay I would love to play h4 my
problem is after h4g four I gotta move
my knight back right I got to go back to
h6 and then maybe after h4 g6g for
Knight h6 he'll play h3 maybe King f3
I'm not sure and then I got my knight
kind of like squander and you know like
you know he's off ranch so to speak okay
first of all my is my turn my turn
so I mean White's future ideas to go h3
rook h1 and g4
that's true so like for example after a
4h 3 hmm not so easy a so black is kind
of up against up against a the dilemma a
difficult decision
yeah I could play rook the c8 and then
f6 and that's it that's a very good
concept right of course I can't leave
this guy Haines
so almost all my preparations might
depend upon has to start with a four
it's tough isn't it I mean it's like you
know you got to understand what
struggles I was having you know and and
you know like how do I keep him under
wraps because I'm first of all I'm
afraid of g4 secondly if I try to get
active or proactive with a move like a
four then I'm allowing him before and
suddenly there's an entirely different
front and I may not be prepared for the
action to swing to the other side yes
okay there's this drawback with the move
a3 you lose control of the square b3
right so after a2 a3 a5 a4 then that B
file as Michael pointed out earlier is
really useful
I could play rook to b8 to b3 so
well that would cost me a pond and I'm
not - yeah exactly
and so I which f6 and to recapture with
the pond that's an idea f6 pawn takes
pawn takes and yeah and but I am just
creating a weakness there on the e6 a
little bit at least I don't know I don't
know so what did I come up with
of course you guessed it whoops that's
not the right yeah I played Knight h6 I
played Knight h6 somebody help me out
here why on earth did I play Knight h6
yeah what one of the things that really
Haughton happens in chess and I don't
mean to I don't want to make a
differential between amateur players and
professional players but amateur players
prepare threats right like they want to
do this this this this and get you
professional players are anticipating
the threats that you're going to do and
they take measures before you even get a
chance to threaten them so obviously
White's intent is to threaten me with
h3g for I get out of the way before you
so the idea here is just as you
described it the knight jumps back from
a beautiful beautiful square but there's
a very important concept behind this
move which is about to be revealed and
that is after h3 White's already he's
all set up to play that King f3g for
that I've been fearing
and I played the scrappy f5 okay so I
got remember you guys were you're
starting to come around to the idea that
maybe I should play f6 get some counter
play okay my knight jumped out of the
way and I played f5 and guess what his
knights trapped Mike though he doesn't
want to play Knight to g5 because I will
take it take it I'll come back and I'll
be attacking this night on F this pawn
on e5 in the game
yawn Tim on captured my pawn on f6 and I
recaptured like this why somebody help
me why didn't white play Knight d6 check
you got to take the knight right Bishop
takes d6
he takes d6 and what would you do if you
were black yes sir
okay keep in mind Wright's intention is
to play rook to e1 and attack this pawn
really really fast keep in mind when you
move the knight this pawn is going to be
hanging so how about rook a six and then
after rook e1 then one rook takes pawn
but then I have what happens after
Bishop takes pawn then a future b4 and
whites doing really well
in fact I had a trap this was a trap
Knight d6 I was really really hoping
that I could coax Yan tim'm into this
trap there's a real crafty way what's
another way of attacking this pawn
Knight at seven and in case of rook to
e1
that grows it wouldn't have been just
gross I mean this rook on h8 that hasn't
played any role in the game suddenly is
like Most Valuable Player and my very
next turn is gonna play Knight takes D
six and ninety four and then he has to
sign my score sheet okay
so unfortunately that beautifully laid
trap went to waste because he captured
and I captured okay
he takes FC yes sir and isn't that
interesting you you said it as but as
well as I possibly could have said it
that he's going to end up in the bad
Bishop back on move five or six whatever
it was when I played Bishop f8 and I
said hey my idea is to leave you with a
bad Bishop it's starting to come to
fruition
okay take stakes sorry
after takes takes rook fe1 rook a e1 is
what he played and I played King F set
oops I didn't do that
I played King f7 again it's kind of like
that you know he's he's threatening to
threaten that one day he'll attack my
pawn on e6 so I defend it even before
he's threatened to threaten so King f7
and then he played a remarkable move I
believe yes this is where he played his
remarkable move now it's funny in the
game I was always concerned that maybe
one day he was going to play King f3 and
g4 but in this particular position that
simply is not a threat could somebody
tell me why if he could play to move
King f3 and g4 back to back would I be
worried should I be worried
right
and furthermore after a for example
after for example king of three let's
say I play a for a useful move g4 takes
takes I could actually take it
Knight takes g4 King takes g4 f5 check
and just trade and then my rook on h8
would have an open file here young
conceptually he looked at the position
and he thought that soon this king side
is going to be blown open like you know
there will be pawn moves going around so
he thought it would be best to exit
stage left with his King get his King
out of the way first of all King e2 King
deewan King C to get his King nicely
situated so that when the King side did
explode his King would be out of the way
and my king would be in the line of fire
okay I played rook on h8 to g8 in my
mind's eye I was always worried about
his push g3 g4 so I wanted to
concentrate my firepower as much as I
could on preventing that idea so he
continues with his plan again it's like
we're both in different universes here
but there were parallel universes like
he's doing his thing and again I'm kind
of doing my thing so he's anticipating
that his king is going to be perfectly
safe over here that my king is going to
be involved in a near rapture after a
move like Knight g5 Shaq
takes with a discovered check against my
king night a5g4 resigned so that's how
he's prepared to play I played Knight f5
sidestepping that threat and by the way
reminding white that now with my rook on
g8 there's a pawn on g3 potentially weak
rook g1 and now he played rook Jiwon
defending the pawn and again he's
preparing G for our poll our favorite
moments weighing the scales what's going
on who stands better ideas thoughts
tough huh this is chess this is tough I
mean you know White has the advantage
precisely right exactly and that's there
you go that's right well there you go
and so my move came as a surprise to
young Tim on I played 96 in the immortal
world in him mortal words of my trainer
international master Nikolai Minette
gift me your paw gifts me your paw I
want to take your palm gift me your paw
Knight to be six so now do you want to
allow me to play Knight takes e4 and
then potentially to jump on to this
square III certainly not so what would
you do is white absolutely be b2 b3
defending the pond and now a4
hey man nobody's gonna give you a free
ride you think the king is going to be
ultra safe on c2 well my intention is to
and check yes sir well there's I mean
that well that's a dream well the
position is definitely getting sharper
right I mean the armies are beginning to
clash and suddenly it starts to be time
to calculate move on move my intention
as you said is to capture and bring my
rook down and furthermore to harass
White's King on the other hand there's a
pond that's hanging should he capture it
or not should he punish me for my
ambitious play by capturing my pawn this
is where chess becomes tough now you've
got to calculate
who would like to capture the pond yeah
I don't know I mean I'd like I said I
mean this is a journey for both of us
here I'm trying to discover what was
going on in this game and you know like
literally from the very early play it
was like I'm violating rules and he's
doing things and I didn't know what was
going on I mean I really I'm very
confused at this moment who else would
like to take the part yes sure please
you don't or do I will end you
if you don't take the pawn what else are
you going to do I mean my threat is to
take your pawn and you know get an open
look and if you don't take the pawn mine
I might just go back and defend it okay
he took the problem he did take the pawn
Knight b-26
I took his pond he took my pond and I
took on g3 Rossing that's Dutch for
surprise whoa
I mean how dare I upset his comfortable
position no I mean White was just was
cruising really nicely before that
unexpected surprise came ah the but yon
had seen he had seen he played rook
takes rook takes Knight takes Bishop
takes and bingo bango f5 so his idea
it was that if I captured then the night
would jump and he'd have the open file
this pawn remember my protected past
pawn is now weakened by not having a
defender other than the bishop of course
and furthermore if I play the movie e6e
five which keeps a solid he'll put his
knight on e4 which will be super
powerful right I mean it'd just be like
unstoppable in the middle of the board
and don't forget White has connected
passed pawns himself I mean there might
be a possibility of b4 + c5 coming up
and you know all kinds of things could
go wrong for me in this position right
just okay so what did I do
I can't play the movie five but neither
can I allow him to capture my pawn on e6
I captured here you recaptured right so
here you go ready for this on f5 yes he
did yes there was also that option of
going on Knight captures h5 as we'll see
in then you gots like Knight f4 but as
we'll see the knight is actually very
well placed on f5 it will be worse place
on h5 in view of what I did now what do
you think I did now what is black black
what is black going to do
yes sir
yeah baby yeah pass palms are supposed
to be pushed right that's why we create
pass bonds d3 and isn't it amazing white
is lost just like that it's over yeah
yeah d3 and it's lost no but he has no
defense in the game this suddenly like
shock of all shocks d3 in the game maybe
we'll try to improve but I assure you
rook a1 check Bishop d2 to C 1 D 2 King
captures D 2 Bishop b4 check give me
your rook and your bit not exchange your
rook remember is going to be a rook
check the bishops gonna be here I'm
going to fork King takes check King back
I'll take the rook and if you take my
bishop I'll take your Bishop so I'm
threatening rook a 1 check and D 2
winning anatole rook count them baby
count it and if you move your rook let's
say up the board rookie 4 just as a
thought I'll give you a check and after
Bishop 2 c1
I'll go Bishop a3 and you won't be able
to defend the bishop with the rug so the
only move to stop rook a 1 is fish
Bishop c3 yeah Bishop c3 defending
defending the a1 square and I of course
played I played a four for a reason
which was to create a weakness and I
attacked his weakness by indeed I did
and if I captured the pawn on b3 what's
falling next well pawn on c4 right it's
like cha-cha-cha and not only that isn't
this gonna be so cute I'll go rook takes
b3 Knight takes e4 and mate okay so
after rook a3 he played what could he do
he played King D - yeah so he wants to
capture my pawn on d3
I played rook takes b3 naturally and now
he would be very very happy to be able
to capture my pawn oops my pawn on d3
but he can't why can't he play King
captures d3 yes and how will I win it
though so King takes d3 Bishop to b4
yeah
night like this night was a total bozo
you know is suddenly going to a four and
it wins and also I mean you know ideas
like night takes c4 checkered in the
position so he can't play King takes d3
that loses a piece yon played rook a
100k so he stops isn't and Yanis
inviting me to capture his pawn then he
would capture my pawn Knight takes e4
check King takes d3 if I move my knight
he'll go king c2 and he'll scramble his
way into a bad position but I played a
really cute move here what did I do
really cute
come on baby this is this is the glory
these are well Knight takes e4 check
King takes d3 is not happiness I'm
letting him escape no unfortunately if
this pawn where's protected Knight takes
e4 check would be fantastic that's the
hint
rook a three he will trade rooks and
take my pawn yes sir you know bingo baby
you betcha Bishop b4 so do we see the
switching Zerg what happens in case of
Bishop takes b4 do you take my bishop
Knight check first King goes away then
you take the bishop then your two pawns
out mmm so he didn't do that he played
rook a7 check we'd like to play King e6
yeah King e6 King e6 King e6 loser rook
I didn't say it was easy
so yeah Knights can retreat Knight d4
check man just on the precipice of
victory it's stealing stealing stealing
defeat from the jaws of victory
so King e6 is out of the question so
where did they go correctamundo
he went 97 check where did I go
absolutely we're I'm all nice and safe
King to g5 what could he do he took on
b4 hi thank you
now he can't go to d1 because then it's
mating one you went to e1 I went Rupp
takes b4 and I believe he played rook d7
just a second let me make sure of that
yes he did
rook to d7 yay and what did I do
well rook b2 don't forget that there's
rook takes to you though well after
Thank You rook b1 check rook e1 chick
King f2 now what did I do
ah gosh why didn't I do that I'm not oh
I think I think is there a Rupp d5 check
perhaps that's annoying
I I didn't do I didn't do that I first
took along something else what else did
I do
d2 is probably winning but I think what
I did was stronger stronger I think I
was a not quote afraid at this point I
realized I was winning I thought that if
I allow him to go check and for example
King here or King here you could go
Knight check and somehow get his Knight
back and caused me discomfort I didn't
want any discomfort so what did i do
first
maybe not how about a check where would
he go after check
do you see something yeah I see some
mating patterns perhaps you will be to
check what would happen here if he goes
King f3 Horde his gang on a rock i-95
Jack and I take it so his kings got to
go back baby and if he comes back to e1
I can push the pawn with check but I
have even stronger move than that
exactly if he comes back to e 1 then I
have rookie to check now where is he
gonna go it really doesn't matter let's
suggest just for argument's sake that he
goes to f1 now Knight Shaq notice that
he doesn't have any rook d5 checks
remember before I told you I would be a
little bit discomfort and now I would
just move the pawn up the board so in
this position after check he played back
to g1 just a second that's my new main
line and then I made a move that caused
him to resign and what was that move
what do we say about bass balls
Bush never has d2 and now that so after
d2 if he gives me a rook check I can
come nicely to this square and after
another night check I can come to this
square so rook check King here rook
check King here
he can't take my knight 18:1 so he
resigned
this is not of confusing game like white
was making all of this beautiful moves
positional understanding block hating my
game you know making everything okay and
then just bang it was over so really
after the game like I still kinda kind
of started this up and say how did I win
that jess is weird huh
so after this game we analyzed it
analyzed it analyzed it you don't lose a
game unless you made a mistake
clear right so I defined White's mistake
in this game where did white wood not
only what was White's a mistake but
where did the advantage slip when from
the opening where it was very clear that
white had all of the great things going
in his favor
when did the advantage slip at what
moment you know it's funny this game was
played so so many years ago I ought to
put it in Houdini or one of the chess
engines and find out